avec Yasmine Khayat.
- David Adams, rés d d d d d d .
Des tempêtes et même l'ouragan
Irma, il les a tous vécus.
- The water was here.
un ouragan tel que Ian.
"3,5 d d'ondes de tempête,
c'est ce qu'on a eu", dit-il.
Il avait ignoré l'o
d'acacuation et préféré
rester dans sa maison,
avec sa femme Angéli
- isis storm was different,
it brook all the rules.
le sud-ouest de la Floride,
semant sur s p passage
la destruction et la désolation.
"C'était incessant.
Ça soufflait sans arrêt
au-dessus de nos têtes,
raco
Gorda. Le métal frappait contre
le bâtiment. Il faisa s sombre,
mais pas moyen de savoir
ce qui se passait dehors."rérért
le pire, et c'est ce qui est
arrivé.sssssssssssssssssssssssss
ça s'est arrêté pour reprendre
de plus belle."
"Cela pourrait être l'ouragan
lelulus meurtrier de l'histoire
de la Floride", confirme
Joe Biden, même simpossible de n
des pertes humaines.
La Floride a
de catastrophe majeure dans
l'ensemble de ses comtés.
L'administration fédérale a
accepté d'assumer tous les coûts
"Le niveau de l'eau continue
deononter aujourd'hui même après
la tempête. C'est un événement
qui survient aux 500 ans."
les secours s'organisent
tant bien que mal :
Par voie terrestre quand
À bord d'embarcations dans
les zones inondées..
À coup de hache, s'il le faut,
dans leurs véhicules.
JEAN-PIERRE BLANCHET,
directeur, Centre ESCER
les températures, l'importance
de la convection, la for
de rotation de la tempête...
ce concours de circonstances a
favo
rapide. L'énergie d'un ouragan
se puise dans l'eau auaude,
donc si on réchauffe le climauae
terrestre notamment les océans,
on va donner plus d'énergie aux
tempêtes
- Même sur la côte est de lairi.
DENISE DUMONT, rédactrice, chef,
DGDG, "Le Soleil de la Floride"
- On a eu environ 6 pouces
de pluie en 12 heures.
mais des tornades qui peuvent
être qud d même dévastatrices.
- À Tampa, les dégâts sont
minimes.ELELELELELELELELELELELE,
courtier immobilier
- La tempête est partie,
les rayons de soleil commencent
justement à sortir en finutututt
tourner la page.
- Ian se dirige vers la Caroline
du Sud, laissant derrière
lui un
besoin de beaucoup de temps et
de moyens pour se recotrtruire.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,
Radio-Canada, Montréa